[Musique]
macbeth alors j'y fais coucou au rwanda
tous les matins à 9 heures c'est un
rituel immuable
marie-louise guette l'arrivée de sa
petite fille qui conduit son arrière
petite fille maëlys à l'école des
écoliers des anciens qui apprennent à
bien grandir et bien vieillir ensemble
c'est le credo de la marpa école une
maison d'accueil rurale pour personnes
âgées et trois classes du ce1 au cm2
sous le même toit une aile pour l'école
une pour les vingt-deux logements de val
touraine habitat et des espaces communs
la bibliothèque de restaurants où la
salle d'activités
chaque jour les enseignants proposent
des rendez vous aux quinze résidents de
la marpa musique dite et quelques
mentale selon leurs envies
j'attaque pas tort souvent où tout le
monde qui travaillent est faible
j'attends le pasteur était à refaire
le meilleur salon puis john derrière je
veux du silence mais si vous allez les
voir si les mêmes ils veulent venir
faire la dictée
vous allez les chercher c'est pas grave
tu vas chercher la mamie on verra ça à
tout à l'heure
bonjour s'aventurer jusqu'à midi voilà
la dictée doris et marie-louise sont les
deux premières résidente de la marpa
écoles arrivé à l'ouverture en septembre
aujourd'hui de vrais amis elle apprécie
les moments passés avec les enfants
malgré la fatigue et les douleurs de
l'âge
marie-louise la première fiche ou fethi
pourquoi parce que j aime manon chillas
l'équipe de la glisse du coup je l'avais
dit merci
donc c'est sympa de l'avoir ici est ce
que tout le monde est prêt janvier
légumes nation nation nation nation
je veux bien de dénoncer nation sur le
rappeur que j'avais redécouvre mais
j'allais à l'école en suisse souhaitait
quitter avec ce sans être pénalisés
allemand en informer la facile mais je
fais des choses cachées sur ce qu'est ce
qu'un bon c'est la fumée mais ça c'est
un voilà oui c'est l'accent c'est
beaucoup mais il manque un e parce que
c'est un mot féminin sinon le reste
c'est parfait c'est très bien c'est bien
d'avoir trouvé quel type de liens sacrés
en fait entre les gens une forme
d'amitié parce que moi je suis là dans
mon cadre professionnel mais ce ne sont
pas les résidents ne sont pas des élèves
donc c'est pas le même rapport c'est pas
une amitié comme quand on rencontrerait
des gens à l'extérieur mais il ya un
lien il y aurait un mot inventé je ne
sais pas trop comment ça s'appelle mais
il ya un lien oui l'heure du repas après
quelques tentatives et partager ce
moment tous ensemble
il a fallu trouver une solution
alternative pour concilier le rythme des
papiers des mamies et l'enthousiasmé
débordant des enfants
[Musique]
lorsque vous arrivez un certain âge ce
qui vous importe c'est les tranquilles
au tout départ il devait déjeuner tous
les jours dans la cantine scolaire
mes lapins vous savez les enfants
lorsqu'ils sont à la cantine c'est
l'horreur de détente c'est un très gros
brouhaha est alors donc non les
personnes âgées ça les fatigue et de
trop mais maintenant ce sont les élèves
par petits groupes de 6 qui viennent
déjeuner avec eux nos résidents et alors
là c'est un échange extraordinaire est
vraiment très contente pas bien avec
rage et de vermand jacques était
infamante et des remèdes de grand mère
oui
ça vous fait plaisir d'être ici revient
sur chedjou avec haine l'année prochaine
ne sera plus là mais enfin c'est comme
ça c'est l'école l'allégorie soumaré
luis qu'est ce que vous racontez ça il
ya longtemps on va réviser même expliqué
l'école avant comment c'était pour eux
et donc on se rend compte que quand même
maintenant ça a beaucoup changé wigno
leur expliquer tout ce que c'est a pensé
c'est pas la même chose qu'aujourd'hui
bien sûr c'est pas pareil c'était
comment pour vous enfin pour nous vous
savez on faisait le chemin appelé
d'abord et puis on rentre elle tantôt
pour déjeuner et on repartait et on
n'avait pas des vacances comme ils ont
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
accueil le déjeuner vient l'heure de la
sieste pour les quinze résidents qui
retrouvent leur appartement et leur
tranquillité vue sur la campagne pour
marie-louise cette ancienne agricultrice
ah c'est moi ça c'est mon mari c'est ma
baisse à nos confrères dont les deux
frères sont tous les deux décédés dans
le cocon de son studio des meubles des
photos de famille et les souvenirs d'une
vie de labeur
mais marie louise n'a pas le temps
d'être nostalgique à 95 ans elle a
toujours la bougeotte
claire navez les vastes rigole beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup ça que canto des flashs
pour poser c'est pourquoi je me couche
moi je m'envole jusqu'à dans le bout de
son mini qu'il me sens à peu près je
fais le tour auto
je joins km 500 - la ma est lié ou
celles à miley tous les enfants de
l'école tous les enfants vous
connaissent pas ce qu'ils sont allés
chez votre petite fille ah oui il y en a
pas mal qui ne connaissent mais yann ya
beaucoup de partis qui sont partis aux
écoles ah oui alors sa nouvelle c'est
pareil mais en fait un acte humeur quand
même arrivée au malawi
ça me fait plaisir bon je suis habitué
ça fait une une distraction et bi rompre
l'isolément favoriser l'autonomie et
repousser la dépendance des personnes
âgées en les associant aux enfants un
projet innovant aussi pour les
enseignants qui ont à coeur de former de
futurs citoyens plus ouvert plus
solidaire d idée c'était que profiter du
fait qu'ils vivaient dans les mêmes
locaux ces enfants là pour les
sensibiliser à plein de choses alors
à la dépendance parce que au final voilà
et ses résidents sont là ils sont
autonomes ils peuvent pas forcément tout
faire tout seul donc sensibilisés au
vieillissement
on partage puisque bas quand on est avec
quand on est avec eux et b il ya des
choses à prendre en considération peut
pas se comporter de la même façon même
dans le dans le respect l'attitude des
paroles qu'on les enfants en fait il ne
s'adresse pas forcément de la même façon
aux résidents un qu'avec nous donc voila
c'était si cette idée là de deux
citoyens un jour ce sera à eux de se
prendre en main et puis on faire évoluer
la société dans le sens weaver whitman
certaines des activités périscolaires se
passe dans l aile de la maison de
retraite les résidents du moment adore
les activités manuelles et les jeux de
société qui rami tous les suffrages tous
les âges
quand je dis là dans les premiers de là
on était toutes deux et ben moi j'ai
pour faire le temps dont je prenais
l'aimions et jouer avec les boucaniers
pas perdre à
j'ai ça je connais beaucoup de personnes
âgées comme quoi la marque comme toi du
coup bah je vais pas sa foire pour moi
les étés et puis là du coup j'en connais
plein la g
non c'est des gens semblent c'est mieux
bah oui beaucoup sont des moments qui
sont importants parce que c'est des
moments qui sont conviviaux agréable et
on est tous ensemble s'étale projet en
maître et le vivre ensemble et
l'intergénérationnel toutes les
générations
mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas à la
porte de l'école au fil du temps des
liens se tissent entre les familles des
enfants et les mamies tu peux nous
expliquer bas elles connaissent
puisqu'il vient d'en faire ici leur
droit de visite
c'est pourquoi tu reviens leur rendre
visite
qu'est ce que les indiens sont bâtis fin
de journée chacun retourne chez soi le
temps d'une promenade pour marie-louise
le moment de rêver aussi au lendemain le
jour d anniversaire car chaque mois ici
on fait celui des enfants
l'occasion de faire ensemble des gâteaux
pour tout le monde parents enfants
anciens tous mettre la main à la pâte
montmirail ah oui mais je croyais
sentais bien
brûlot son et lumière dormi oui j'aime
bien dans mes pompes alors affirmé gâtés
au bon si tu lis ça milite alors là
dessus ces dessins qu'il est alors tu
enlèves le zéro entre 5,5 et ça change
que d'être toujours se morfondant
personnes âgées ça ça ça rajeunit jeu
trop moi j'aime bien être avec les
enfants surtout offert des gâteaux
j'aime beaucoup ça en fait j'aimerais
bien aller un petit peu à l'adapter au
calcul mental je me déplace mal et puis
je sais pas comment je vais être assise
la valeur j'ai peur à l'avance 50
millilitres
et là il ya 25 centimes
attention voilà ça commence m a plus de
farine par l'usem fait beaucoup rire
alors là beaucoup d'humour et puis
voilà c'est vrai qu'on est on a tous un
parent d'enfant et feu des activités
c'est à la fois éducatif pour les
enfants c'est là ça occupe les résidents
de la marpa et puis voilà ça permet
aussi de passer un bon moment ensemble
quand on va travailler puis à la fin de
la journée on va
[Musique]
m
ainsi va la vie à la marpa écoles de
survenue de touraine une aventure
humaine entre des écoliers et des
anciens la marque a et coll
une histoire de tolérance et de
solidarité entre quatre générations
[Musique]
hu
dans un domaine écoles
à
un mode de vie ensemble imaginé par les
élus de ce petit village de 400
habitants
face au temps qui passe un modèle unique
pour l'instant qui pourrait bien faire
école en france ou ailleurs
[Musique]